[Music]
it gets busy in October in Zambia's
kazanka National Park that's when the
fruit bats arrived the bats come from
the Democratic Republic of Congo but
also other colonies in Zambia they come
here because at this time of year the
fruits are ready they're ripened mainly
they're feeding on local Masuku fruits
and water berries but also other other
fruits that they just have in the
villages such as mangos and bananas and
any fruit they can find really
every time I see it it's amazing I mean
which funny when at the start of the BET
season when the bats first started
arriving we decided to come down and
just have a look to see how many there
were and even just coming down right at
the start when they're only maybe 10,000
or 20,000 we were blown away the bats
arrival marks the beginning of high
season for Dion Scott he's the park
manager and kasanga is the destination
of the world's largest mammal migration
no one knows exactly why the fruit that
grows here annually draws in some 10
million of the animals many of which fly
great distances but throughout Africa
their habitat is under threat the main
challenges for the bats loss of habitat
so they roost in forests and through
this part of Africa in in rainforests
mainly the bat forest itself is very
small it's only about one kilometer long
and about 4 or 500 meters wide the main
threat to the forest here Akos anchor is
fire
earlier in the big fire came through
this part of the bat forest and the soil
in this area is a peat soil and it burns
and so the fire comes in underground and
burns out the roots of the trees and
that's what's happened to this tree it's
burnt up inside the tree and then it's
completely killed it the fires are often
laid by poachers they burn the grass
away so that it grows back faster fresh
grass tempts antelopes to the open
clearings where the poachers can pick
them off the authorities try to prevent
poaching with fire breaks and regular
patrols but the many people living on
the edges of the park see the animals
mainly as a source of food if we see any
sign we go for an ambush let's say for
instance we saw footprints entering the
park through the path we have to go
there and lay an ambush and if we are
inside the park and we heard the gunshot
we have to make a follow up like at
night they use torches to shine yeah so
we you can see a torch at the far
distance and you have to track them
education is important because the
locals tend to be frightened of the
nocturnal animals
[Music]
bats are associated with disease and
sorcery so the project regularly invites
parties at school children from the
surrounding communities to enjoy the
spectacle guide explains the fruit bats
way of life on location that helps
change attitudes towards the harmless
mammals it's usually the first time
children have seen the natural marvel
that takes place yet on their doorstep
after teaching the young ones these
young ones will take their messages the
messages to their parents if the parents
can know about bats
then welcome to up a lot of bats gazonga
a lot of people in the community of
misconception about bats because they
are nocturnal animals as well so other
people say that tea with most of the
witch clerks uses bats but looking at
the way they are they are not they are
just flow collect fruit bats it costs a
lot of money to protect the bats and
financing is hard to come by tourism
generates most of the necessary income
people who come to the park have money a
stay here isn't cheap but the project
needs the funds to survive
we came here because it's a different
part of Africa and a part of our forest
first year of Africa we've never been to
before the bats were here for the big
excitement is also the Langer Falcons
who are gathering as well the fruit bats
play an important role in the ecosystem
here they are food for many predators
and they also spread seeds with their
droppings a bat can fly up to a hundred
kilometres and night in kasanga Park
with the forest he are now protected
Dion Scott says the flying mammals can
live here undisturbed I think there's a
great future for them as long as we can
continue to protect the habitat that
they that they come to roost in and that
they come to feed on and we're doing an
absolute best to try and protect it more
as long as we can keep doing it they
have a great future here at kasanga
there's no real quiet here until the end
of the year when the bats take off again
but next year millions of them will be
back in this little corner of protected
forest in northeastern Zambia